نقدر بشده دعم الاداره الامريكيه بقياده
بايدن ولا يعني ذلك انه ليست بيننا خلافات
لا احتاج الى مساعده لاداره علاقاتنا مع
الولايات
المتحده اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم بقيمه 17 مليار
دولار رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي مايك
جونسون يكشف عن تشريع يقضي بتقديم مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاسرائيل في اطار حربها على
غزه و تستخدم هذه الاموال للمساعده في
تحديث انظمه الدفاع الصاروخي الاسرائيليه
وشراء انظمه اسلحه متقدمه وانتاج المدفعيه
والذخائر تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه
في الرابط الموجود
بالتعليقات الامم المتحده تقول ان القتال
العنيف الفاشر عاصمه اقليم دارفور ادى الى
سقوط قتلى وجرحى ونزوح واسع النطاق والحاق
اضرار في البنيه التحتيه في الوقت الذي
حذر فيه برنامج الغذائ العالمي من الوضع
الكارثي في السودان مؤكدا ان عدد الجياع
ارتفع الى الضعف مقارنه بالعام الماضي وان
نحو 18 مليون شخص يواجهون خطر الجوع الحال
وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه تعلن مقتل 20 شخصا
في هجوم قالت ان قوات اوكرانيه شنته على
مخبز في منطقه لوغانسك الواقعه تحت سيطره
القوه الروسيه شرقي اوكرانيا ادى الى
انهياره بشكل كامل مشيره الى استمرار
اعمال انتشال عالقين تحت الانقاذ في حين
وصفت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه الهجوم
بالارهابي الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يفوز
في الانتخابات التمهيديه على حساب منافسيه
من الحزب الديمقراطي في ولايه ساوث
كارولاينا ليجتاز اول اختبار انتخابي له
في سعيه الى الفوز بولايه رئاسيه ثانيه
حيث وصف بايدن فوزه بانه تمهيد للانتصار
مجددا على ترامب الى
اللقا